sooner or later the humans are going to  fight us up here you should have known  this day was coming  are we supposed to follow our king and  remain in silent disease we need to go  to Paris now we've been hiding here too  long let's go to a rightful home if we  were on earth we would have a glorious  planet to live on  thrive you're talking about betraying  your brother you're talking about  freedom you're blind to his intentions  right or wrong he dangerous what I'm  talking about is freedom freedom through  all in humans are you going to use your  voice and kill your only brother  [Music]  [Music]  we will love that anyone for anything  Sophos we will create our destiny  nothing can keep us for being quick  you  you